these guys realized quick if they were
gonna claim that cigarettes were not
addictive they better have proof this is
the man that rely on he's been testing
the link between nicotine and lung
cancer for 30 years and hasn't found any
conclusive results the man's a genius we
could disprove gravity this is called
industry-funded research and while it is
a science unfortunately it's oftentimes
a science of deception when faced with
inconvenient facts companies will
sometimes pay for research to find the
opposite conclusion so they can deny
guilt the most notorious example for
this was the tobacco industry who
famously created an organization called
the Council for tobacco research to
fight the idea that cigarettes caused
lung cancer dr. little have any
cancer-causing agents been identified in
cigarettes
no none whatever either in cigarettes or
in any product of smoking as such now
fast-forward a few decades the public
eventually found out the truth and the
CTR was exposed as a sham but as the
world turned its attention to new
problems one industry found itself in
familiar crosshairs we Americans spend
more money on slots than on movies
baseball and theme parks combined but
with the modern slot machines there's a
greater potential for a dangerous side
effect
gambling addiction problem gambling has
become an epidemic
last year the American Psychiatric
Association reclassified pathological
gambling as an addiction Las Vegas and
other casinos are like giant
laboratories and the features that earn
higher will stick and those that don't
will drop away the formula they've hit
upon happens to be one that's highly
addictive the gambling industry was
being accused of preying on the wallets
of addicted gamblers addicted gamblers
that they helped create with their
carefully designed machines
Howard Shafer researcher at Harvard
noted this increased addictiveness of
modern games like slots by calling them
the crack cocaine of gambling in the
midst of all this horrible press the
gambling industry needed a strategy to
stay alive luckily for them they had
watched someone else go through this and
had learned a few things
you can't completely deny the facts the
cigarette industry tried it and it
didn't work the truth eventually comes
out so they came up with a different
plan instead of denying gambling
addiction they would embrace the problem
publicly and also take an extremely
active role in researching the science
of gambling addiction by doing this they
could frame the discussion of the
addiction the way they wanted to and so
the National Center for Responsible
gaming was created funded by casino
dollars and here's how they describe
gambling addiction today so what exactly
is a gambling disorder and why do some
people struggle with it while others do
not one point that research clearly
shows is that gambling disorders are
closely linked with other psychological
problems including depression and
substance abuse we also know that over
time proximity to casinos does not
impact the prevalence of gambling
disorders and while the vast majority of
people gamble responsibly approximately
1% of Americans are diagnosed with a
gambling disorder now it might not
surprise you many of their findings are
in direct contradiction to scientific
studies that aren't backed by casino
dollars but rather than nitpicking
everything I want to focus on their
macro message the biggest thing is that
they want to imply that addicts are born
that way they're not created from a
product if you can blame addiction on
brain problems within the addict you are
indirectly vindicating the gambling
machines of course this is what the
casinos want the most dangerous idea is
that they have anything to do with
creating addicts so instead they say
it's not the product that causes the
problem the problem is already within
the addict and just expresses itself in
the addiction the senior research
director for the NCR G Christine Riley
makes this bias explicit well things are
not addictive they're just not if you
don't have that vulnerability the odds
are you won't get addicted and the NCR G
is willing to put up a lot of money to
any scientists who will agree with them
and surprisingly one of the people who
took them up on that offer was Howard
Shafer the man quoted earlier as calling
slots the crack cocaine of gambling
today he tells a much different story
that casino games like slots aren't
addictive and if this seems like a 180
to you you're not the only one when
asked about this contradiction he tried
really hard to
where the two opinions but at one point
you said slot machines were the crack
cocaine of gambling I did say and how
does that square with what you're
telling me today not everybody who uses
crack cocaine becomes addicted but
nobody's gonna sit here and try to tell
me crack cocaine is an addictive and if
this is like crack cocaine the
conclusion is that it's addictive I
don't come to the same conclusion
because that's majority of people that
have used cocaine have not developed
cocaine addiction only a small minority
and the same would be true with example
okay now obviously Howard Shafer would
say the millions of dollars in research
funding he's received hasn't tanked in
his research but in Schafer's words I
don't come to the same conclusion
because if he started to say the wrong
things a lot of that funding would
disappear research funding from places
like the NCR gee but also MGM Resorts
and draftkings just to name a few and
this strategy to buy scientific research
to shift the burden of responsibility
onto the addict and away from the
product has been great for casinos
public image but it isn't the first time
someone tried it certain of the
published data seem to show an
association between certain types of
cancer and excessive use of cigarettes
now we're very interested in finding out
what kind of people are heavy smokers is
it a different nervous type of person is
it a person who was reacting differently
to strain or stress because it is very
clear that certain people just can't
can't take it
[Music]
certain people just can't take it this
is exactly the same framing casinos use
why do some people struggle with it
while others do not certain people just
can't take it it's a simple powerful
argument and whether or not anyone fully
believes them that isn't the point the
gambling industry wins even if all they
do is confuse you if they can cast doubt
on the scientific consensus of what
causes gambling addiction
they've won because nobody's gonna
legislate on something that the
scientific community isn't agreed upon
and the problem of deliberate
misinformation is widespread it goes
beyond just smoking and gambling you can
find it at Exxon where knowledge of
climate change was deliberately ignored
and you can find it in the sugar
industry when they paid for research to
blame heart disease on fat instead of
sugar you can even find it in my
favorite soda company Coca Cola when
they publicly said they care about the
problem of soft drinks but deny it in
the science so if we know this problem
is widespread why do we continue to fall
for it there are two main models we use
to deal with research that has a
conflict of interest you can completely
prohibit it or you can disclose the
conflict of interest and use peer review
as a check and balance for a long time
we've used the latter and assumed peer
review would be enough because
prohibition just seems extreme but many
critics are now wondering whether this
is effective at keeping out bad science
because the ncrj disclosed it and yet
they still manage to shove 200 papers
through the peer-review process even the
tobacco industry funded research that
slipped favorable articles passed the
peer-review process in my view the risk
is too great I think that more journals
should seriously consider the
prohibition model when dealing with
papers with an obvious conflict of
interest we live in a world where the
truth is not agreed upon very often and
the last thing we need is for science a
beacon of objectivity to be cluttered by
bad actors who just want to confuse the
scientific consensus and prevent
progress so far what are the conclusions
reached by your organization in my
opinion to single out smoking as of
course legend
is on the evidence to date complete down
justified well thank you very much sir
for help well thank you very much for
letting me put our views forward you
better have a cigarette before you go
ahead sir before you go we have a
sponsor our very first sponsor so thank
you to audible for sponsoring this video
you can get a free audiobook and 30-day
trial by going to audible.com/veritasium
this channel are inspired by books and
one of the ways I get through books is
by listening to them in the car at the
gym
walking whatever it's a great way to
just take some books down in your free
time today I wanted to recommend hooked
by near Isle which is about how people
engineer addictive products and I think
it goes right in line with this video if
you want to learn more so once again you
can get a free audiobook like hooked by
near IO or any book that you choose from
their amazement I bury by going to
audible.com/veritasium
[Music]